transcriptomics three is a course
dedicated to advanced methods of
analysis that will allow us to find
meaningful patterns in beta
especially those complex patterns that
are present in big datasets in this
video we will review the steps that we
have to take to find download and
process a dataset as well as prepare for
such analysis this is the first part of
the transcriptomics course where we will
learn about the data set as well as the
questions that are posed in the study
that we will follow after the data is
prepared we will explore how to analyze
the prepared table of expression the
study we will follow is an example from
a publication written by Damon from a
research group at a company called
Genentech their publication is titled
modeling precision treatment of breast
cancer the publication is interesting
because the authors assembled a data set
of about 50 different breast cancer cell
lines that represent the whole spectrum
of breast cancer variations the authors
of this paper analyzed genomic
transcriptomics and proteomics data to
identify molecular profiles of breast
cancer they then collected an efficacy
measurement of commonly used and
experimental cancer drugs on the same
samples let's see what the benefits are
in a sequencing as well as RNA
expression can offer from molecular
classification of breast cancer
histological analysis of a tumor can be
illustrated by looking at a mammogram
which is an x-ray picture of breast
cancer that doctors used to look at
early signs of breast cancer and
suspected lumps in this example you can
see that the tumor has been highlighted
once the tumor is found it's critical to
establish whether it is malignant or
benign as well as what tissue is
originating from once the tumor is
characterized by its phenotype
additional information can be obtained
by checking for the presence of specific
proteins characteristic of cancer if
these proteins are known
immunohistochemistry can be used to find
if they are expressed or not specific
molecular markers are characterized for
cellular
events such as the proliferation or cell
death these are typically referred to as
biomarkers based on these biomarkers we
can know something about the tumor and
in many cases we can develop a treatment
option that is planned and tailored to
the individuals profile protein
expression especially when it's measured
with immunohistochemistry our fish
provides us with a select number of
biomarkers that we can check for
oftentimes immunohistochemistry is used
in combination with gene expression
panels here on the right you'll see a
Pam 50 panel it is a panel of 50 genes
that shows their expression high
expression is shown is green and low in
red so now we can see these patterns or
profiles of gene expression using
variations of these genes researchers
started classifying breast cancer into
several subtypes luminal a normal like
luminal B her2 enriched and basal like
Pam fifty uses a fifty gene signature
that can be tested using qrt-pcr other
panels include Oncotype DX which has a
21 gene recurrent score and mamuh print
which has a 70 gene signature of which
the latter two have been approved by the
FDA for use in the United States the Pam
fifty is now called Pro Sigma breast
cancer in the online course you'll be
able to view a video on how molecular
classification of breast cancer is
changing the clinical classification
approaches for both the diagnosis and
treatment of this disease in this video
dr. Neil brass will explain how text
generation sequencing data is changing
the breast cancer profiling for clinical
Diagnostics dr. BRAF is the chief
medical officer for agenda which is a
company that is commercializing the men
print panel for breast cancer breast
cancer is a heterogeneous disease both
genetically as well as clinically
and there's a need for histological
molecular and functional classification
systems that can have in the devising of
appropriate treatments as well as the
predicting of clinical behavior
histological classification has been
considered a valuable tool for
classification of breast cancer subtypes
for decades
owing to its diagnostic as well as
limited prognostic value it
characterizes different types on the
basis of histological features such as
glandular formation nuclear pleomorphic
ISM as well as mitotic rate luminal a
luminal B basal like normal breasts like
her 2 plus and recently cloud and low
have been identified as molecular
subtypes of breast cancer on microarray
based gene expression hence the
evolution of molecular classification
that has great potential for predicting
a therapeutic response
but how can this molecular subtyping be
used because many patients characterize
with such methods were observed for such
a long period of time we can assess risk
levels for recurrence as well as
survival in this chart you'll see a
Mayer Kaplan curve of survival or
recurrence based on to clinical gene
panel Pam 50 and Oncotype DX these
panels separate patients into three
groups high medium and low risk based on
these assessments a treatment is
selected traditional treatments for
cancer are surgery radiotherapy as well
as chemotherapy each one of these
treatments can have harmful side effects
and are known to be effective in
specific situations for example tumors
are typically irradiated before surgery
or if they are considered to be somewhat
benign chemotherapy target cell
proliferation and often affects many
other cells in the body not just the
tumor that's causing severe discomfort
in patients and in some cases this leads
to complications however since the 1990s
there's been a new type of treatment
that started emerge in clinical use
this is targeted cancer therapy one such
treatment is called Herceptin which is a
monoclonal antibody that blocks the her2
receptor blocking it from receiving a
growth factor and thus preventing cell
growth now let's take a look at the
abstract of the paper which summarizes
what the authors were trying to do as
well as the analyses they performed
yellow words are highlighted as the
topics of this publication one try
lights the methods that were used and
many of them are discussed in detail
throughout this course from a quick
reading of the abstract we find that the
authors used machine learning algorithms
to identify molecular features that
associated with different breast cancer
groups and then they associated those
with treatment efficacy let's start by
finding the molecular data that they
used and prepare it for such analysis
on ncbi data is organized into bio
projects these contain links to
publications various metadata about
samples and if raw data is available it
can be downloaded here is how you find a
data set and download information about
these samples this is going to be
important for us to understand what
we're dealing with what a cell line is
where it is and whatever information is
known about each sample can also be
found here let's take a look at the
downloaded table and see what's inside
data is stored in a compressed format or
SRA which stands for sequence read
archive this SRA archive contains runs
that start with SR R which stands for
sequence read runs if you download and
extract the SRA archive you'll find that
they contain fast queue files with
extensions with underscore one and
underscore two at the end looking at the
metadata given in the project we see
that the data was produced using pair
and sequencing this is a technique that
uses simultaneous reading of each
fragment from both ends thus improving
the quality of sequencing in addition to
the file name and its downloaded
location the metadata shows cell line
names that are used in each run as well
as the clinical subtype associated with
that sample to save us some time
we already downloaded and unpacked this
archive preparing it for use on the
platform if we download the ncbi sra
table we will see the names of each
sample or run name of the associated
cell line as well as clinical subtype
these are luminal basal Cloudland low
and normal like
these molecular subtypes have different
prognosis morphology and patterns of
gene expression to see whether the same
groups can be found on the RNA seek data
we have to convert the SRA read files
into structured data
now it's time to convert the read data
from SRA files into a table of
expression which will be able to analyze
using various machine learning as well
as data mining techniques depending on
the type of pipeline of your choice you
can download a smaller set of eleven
samples with only two subtypes or you
can download a full set of the 52 cell
lines the data will be an fpkm format
which stands for fragment per kilo base
of transcript per million mapped reads
this means that the gene expression
level is already adjusted for in total
number of reads in each sample as well
as the length of a given gene this
measure is typical for RNA seek outputs
from parent sequencing go ahead and
download the file which is labeled
expression Gene's cell lines txt once
downloaded you can open the file in
Excel to see the contents
the results of the pipeline will give us
a table of expression not only is this
table normalized for read count and gene
length other transformations have
already been done to the table to remove
genes with zero expression across all
samples once you eliminate genes with
zero expression you end up with
approximately seventeen thousand out of
our original 69 thousand genes RNA seek
data has been shown to have skewed
distributions as well as under equal
variances and extreme values that are
called outliers most statistical tests
including the ones that we use in our
analyses have an assumption of normality
the three affer mentioned issues violate
those assumptions there are a number of
normalization approaches that may be
used a standard approach includes
conversion of values to log scale and
adjusting the distribution to account
for technical variability of low
expressions on the T - bio info platform
both of these can be done using quantum
normalization utilities this utility can
be found on the main areas of analysis
page quantum normalization procedures
are important to transform distributions
both between and amongst different
samples to have the same distribution
this removes unwanted technical
variation that could cause perceived
differences between samples when there
are in fact no differences in terms of
biology in addition while normalizing
data we will use a log transformation
that makes it easier to interpret
differences in gene expression
before we start looking at specific
genes we need to summarize the full data
set to do so we often use a box plot
that shows us all the values that are
distributed between the samples if we
have multiple data sets which is in our
case a sample data of gene expression
with multiple samples box plots help
compare the samples using statistical
properties these are the mean median and
the bulk of the data which is the
interquartile range versus the outliers
when we prepare a box plot of a typical
I may see data set we can see that the
gene expression levels are heavily
skewed in linear scale the majority of
the data points are lower expressed
genes have very low values between 0 and
10 and the remaining outliers
specifically the higher expressed values
or those between 10 and 16,000 are going
to be barely visible at the bottom of
the box plot in this box plot you can
see that the majority of the data points
that are supposed to be in the
interquartile range are barely visible
however the outliers which represent the
top 25% of the data in the box plot are
going to be stretched out and clearly
visible this type of distribution will
interfere with many of the statistical
tests that we plan to use to analyze our
gene expression data here you can see
that normalization aligns the mean of
samples as well as adjust distribution
the higher the threshold the more lined
our data will be if we do box plots for
all 52 samples it's going to be hard to
spot any abnormalities but after
normalization data is much more visible
and we can even see patterns in the data
some samples have lower variance as well
as low overall expression the upper
inner quartile range there's also an
outlier sample that seems to have an
abnormal high expression in the upper
quartile as well as higher overall mean
but if we were to normalize only a
portion of the data it would look very
different notice here that the means are
all around 1.5
and the distributions are very similar
this tells us that normalization is
dependent on both how many samples we
have and which samples are normalized in
this data set now we can use this
normalized data with the clinical
annotation that we have from the SRA run
table to perform our analysis in our
next session we'll use this data perform
clustering and identify groups of
samples let's review the steps step one
is the biopsy process and in step two
this is separated into tumor and non
tumor cells here single-cell suspensions
are magnetically labeled using a non
tumor cell depletion cocktail that's
contained in a tumor cell isolation kit
according to the protocol that's
included these cocktails labelled non
tumor cells and thus enable the
isolation of unlabeled tumor cells DNA
extraction from the tumor occurs during
step 3 in step 4
we have sequencing and analysis we
combine data with existing samples in
step 5 and finally in step 6 we analyze
our results we do this by combining the
data from a given sample with other data
that we already know about by comparing
them to the data that we already know we
can find similarities to one of the
known groups in this video we review the
steps that we have to take to find
download and process a data set as well
as prepare for such analysis